hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one stop shop for everything
towns like entertainment guess what
folks guess what today we're talking all
about comic books the things that are
all over the walls I think it's in the
name of the show the thing that on the
table looks crazy right and we have been
talking about comics every week but you
know you guys don't seem notice that so
we're gonna take an entire episode to
talk about all comic book stuff we're
gonna talk about the free comic book day
we're gonna talk about all all new all
different Marvel we're gonna talk about
DC rebirth and some of the stuff if
these guys are reading right now um I'm
your host Walter panizzi I by the way um
and to my right over here that's you
iono yeah I Anna wait back back at it
again thank you again with the 90s look
exactly nine thank you overall really
just a family night you're right right
whatever very nice very nice retro
throwback throwback day and over here we
got mr. brian porter are you doing it's
a nice hat thank you see it once in a
while it's pretty cool I'm not Irish
meddling not Irish at all no Irish blood
whatsoever none I know the Red hbu
doesn't give it away I do like potatoes
though a couple of potatoes for you well
let's get into this thing here hmm and I
can do that all time to work okay all
right first um once again I always want
to thank you guys for commenting and
everything about what you want to see us
cover keep doing that we will cover as
much as what you want to see as cover as
possible and we're still getting good
reaction on the DC animated movies see
our favorites we each individually
picked one movie they're all Batman
movies sorry yeah it was our favorite
share with other ones that all right
chill out okay um so there's so much
positive feedback to that a lot of
people wants to cover that in Alien
series we will do it at some point in
some form we will cover that in Alien
series and I think more movies and more
of the DC animated stuff as possible
where I cover on the show over the
summer so stay tuned for that but today
we're talking about all comic books iono
we're gonna start with you what are you
reading over in model right now what's
going on with only well different as you
can tell I'm not reading any Marvel
right now I'm reading too much model
right now there's a bunch of stuff going
on and all need a whole different marble
and a lot of you I've noticed in the
common
we're talking about how you're not super
into comics when you kind of don't know
where to get started and now is a really
great place to kind of jump in because
they're rebooting a lot of the titles in
Marvel and in DC so it's a really good
starting off point to kind of jump in
and I related to Doctor Who you start
off with a new doctor and then you get
all the back story that goes with it um
so I'll start off first by talking about
one of my favorite titles and that's
squirrel girl the current issue number
seven right now is a
choose-your-own-adventure squirrel which
is amazing and this is a really good
starter comic I think as well because
first off she's got some amazing
superhero puns but you gotta love and
then she also has almost like a pokedex
of villains going on and it's like a
stack of trading cards that Deadpool has
made for her so that she can go through
and learn all the stats on who she's
fighting against which I just absolutely
loves also right now in the Marvel
Universe is a really cool eight-part
crossover series with the spider women
and currently as of this taping we're
only on like the fifth issue so if you
want to pick it up you got to start with
the spider women alpha and that's the
first in the series and they have this
tiny little crossover checklist here for
you so that covers a spider woman spider
Gwen and silk so we go between the
worlds of earth-616 and Earth 65 and I
recommend reading some of the spider
Gwen and it's only like seven issues in
right now six or seven issues in right
now but you don't have to but a lot of
the stuff that happens they're currently
trapped in earth 65 so it gives a little
bit of a better background as to what's
going on um including how it starts
which is a spider Gwen takes Jessica
Drew and Cindy moon out for brunch on
earth 65 from our 6 16 and they get
trapped and they have to deal with that
and right now depending on if you read
Spider Woman at all she just had a baby
she became pregnant in the whole time
traveling vortex of stuff that's
definitely the time you want to get
pregnant right right and not really
understand completely how that's
happening so
you can jump into just this series
without having read those because it
sounds like they're doing a really good
job of like explaining a little bit how
stuff is happening without giving like
too much backstory and keeping a little
bit of an intrigue going on also in
earth 65 I love that there's a starbucks
i need a starbucks mug Tony Stark has a
coffee enterprise and I love that I love
I need that so bad um and silks family
is missing in the silk series she was in
I guess captivity she was kept alone for
a while and when she comes out she finds
out her family's gone so in this series
also we get to see her try to find her
family in the new series and find out
who's may be chasing them or after them
I don't want to give too much away but
go check it out it's a really cool
little mini series to look at Plus in
the spider Glen series there's some
really cool stuff going on with villains
and we get to see some well-known
characters maybe die off maybe become
you villains I don't know I don't wanna
get too much way but Captain America is
a black girl and I love it I think
that's super awesome and the design of
her costume is really cool too and I
like that little throwback to the world
war two and the the air air women that
fall back then was pretty cool so spider
baby black cap that's there's a lot
going on it's really cool Oh check it
out check it out other than that i would
say black widow was a really good place
to start as well we've only got three
issues out right now and we get to see a
little bit into her past and what's
going on with her a little bit the first
one is basically just action-packed it's
like a whole chase sequence so if
nothing else go look at that go look at
a comic book store what are what are you
reading right now in my recorder I'm not
reading too much Marvel I stick mainly
towards DC now but um right now I'm
reading Deadpool spider-man I love the
bromance between Deadpool and spider-man
their frickin sterically gether and they
just have a really good dynamic and
that's a good series i'm really liking
and then um I've got a uncanny uncanny
Avengers I think it is Deadpool's and
the Avengers now they got some
equal interesting people in that so
that's cool and then um pretty much any
other deadpool comic that they have i
read and i think that's it well I know
you like Spencer and punishes restarting
over as well we have Punisher issue
number one here so you should also check
that out also daredevil and Punisher
everywhere I know a lot of you have been
watching it right now on Netflix so go
check out the comics as well I just
played and they're starting over so it's
a really good starting place for you so
those are my suggestions to go out other
than that I'm mostly reading Marvel
right now my only DC would be my man
girl Babs who woulda guessed it I know
criteria would I even thought on at all
nothing whatsoever that it's going to be
better there she's gonna be restarting
over in the rebirth so I'm really
looking forward to the rebirth
specifically because of that because
right now it looks like they're gonna be
finishing up uh like a battle at Gotham
Academy I'm not really sure um that's
kind of what they're setting up and
she's been having some complaints about
the chip in her head going on and slow
reflexes and stuff but it sounds like
she just needs to get away from it all
and it sounds like what they're gonna do
is make her a travel agent so we're
gonna get some really cool postcard
moments and some really cool artwork I
hope for that and some solo Batgirl
missions it's gonna be my research so
that'll be out and july july 13th i
think is issue number one so go check
that out a lot of stuff coming up in the
summit for Marmol it sounds like okay
we're gonna go over to DC now there's a
lot of stuff going on around about DC
rebirth can we start talking about DC
rebirth real quick well let's let's lead
up to it a little bit okay we got a
couple of big things happening in the
end of new 52 right now um before DC
rebirth comes into it one of my
favorites I've been reading it since it
came out it is a phenomenal run is kapu
low and snyder's batman i love it issue
50 was out a couple of weeks or a few
weeks ago and then issue 51 just came
out issue 50 was awesome specifically
because batman is back Bruce Wayne is
finally back in the bat costume a new
bat costume BTW because it was it's an
awesome costume i really like the new
take on it and i'm so glad that he's
back
because even though robo Batman bunny
suit Jim Gordon was cool I got sick of
it I'm not gonna lie I got sick of it I
was like bring back Bruce and this story
itself now is like pretty awesome and it
sucks that they're rebooting it I kind
of be as schneider and caputo we're done
after this issue this is their last
issue lovely cover by the way and I just
want more sense Utah guys gotta get a
personal connection with them thank you
get to talk to I did get to see talking
the great guys I love their stories but
um it this is uh this Batman suit is
awesome it's got a yellow I don't know
if you could see that it's got a yellow
outline on the bat symbol I think it
looks really awesome this issue was
insane by the way all these robo bats
suits going into like straight-up
villain mode controlled by mr. bloom
which is a fantastic character by the
way mr. bloom is like the big for last
ten issues he's been like the big bad
and it is awesome a lot of really good
stuff in issue 50 so I'm really really
sad to see that go but you know new
Batman title rebirth let's see what
happens no I'm open to it and then
another one that I'm really enjoying
right now is insane is Justice League
Justice League 49 just came out I just
read it uh it's really good for the
story at some crazy with the dark
side wards part 9 this is an epic epic
storyline with the dark side wore dark
side got killed Mobius anti-life
equation like basically we got like new
gods but not new gods that you know of
like um you know Batman's in the Mobius
chairs Superman got hit with this crab
apocalypse solar energy and I'll he's
this black and white badass insane guy
the flash is like the death flash he's
got this side it looks awesome Shazam's
all crazy Lex Luthor is like the new
dark side it's insane and one of the big
things I was really looking forward to
49 was they were supposed to do the
origin of the Joker who the Joker was
his identity it wasn't as ordinate it
was his identity from the Mobius chair
issue 43 Batman asks who was the Joker
who is the
Kearney's like no that's not possible
they never went anywhere with it and
they're like oh yeah issue 49 it's gonna
tell who the Joker is in the snap i just
read it no Joker what like maybe you can
push it back I think they did because
this this book has been um not on time
for like months and months of notes
which is a pain in the ass but they said
it's gonna be continued finished in
issue 50 which is cool so I can't wait
to see how that ends so I read a lot of
different DC no jug Justice League
Batman and read a lot of green lantern
um you know Batman Beyond is really good
Oh what are you looking forward to
Batman Beyond in the rebirth yeah what
do you think it's gonna be in the
bathroom I want Terry my don't k I don't
know who I think I want Terry me I love
hey guys yeah I mean we futures and in
him like dying and what not like I want
more Terry McGinnis how long is Tim
Drake been in the Bambi on sue now it's
been a while I isn't it it's 12 issues
control visuals issues and it is um but
I want Terry me guys yeah but like a lot
of different stuff so I'm kind of
interested in seeing that I'm kind of
like very hesitant with rebirth because
it's just like you had that whole
convergence thing like last year
whatever it was a few years ago and
they're supposed to be like a like a
soft reboot they were bringing old story
lines back kind of bringing everything
back together I think it worked pretty
well and it you freshened it up a little
bit but now that they're doing rebirth
it's like okay I get it you're trying to
get away from the new 52 because I got a
lot of but it's like you're just
changing around so much stuff and it's
like I gotta restart again and all this
stuff and I don't know how much of it
I'm gonna like so I'm pretty like Ron
but another rebirth yeah yeah there's
there's been a lot of controversy about
rebirth I mean I've just seen on online
a lot of people talking about how it's
you know so new after new 52 there is
what five years i think 2011 new 52 came
out and that was a really drastic reboot
where they read numbered you know
everything from number one and now
they're gonna go back to the original
numbering for actually kind of like
comics in action yeah yeah yeah I
shouldn't come here right that's crazy I
mean they're kind of going back on the
word a little bit I think you're just
rewriting the wrongs they kind of saw
how the public
reacted to it and they're kind of like
you know hey we get it we're sorry
here's the renumber rings with the those
50 issues back into it so I mean it's
pretty i I get it that's kind of cool
but you know I got this previews DC
Comics rebirth previews paging through
it there's a lot of stuff happening and
one of the big things I'm noticing is
the by month are shipping twice monthly
a lot of these titles are shipping twice
monthly now and that is a lot should put
on these writers but on these artists
and it's like it's a lot of money too
yeah yeah they're dropping the price
down I think draw the line at 299 was
the mantra back in the day and so like
they're like something till the line at
999 so I kind of like they're dropping
them down but a lot of these are twice
month shipping twice monthly and that's
crazy like the new Green Lantern 1 i'm
pretty sure it's gonna be shipping twice
monthly and it's like okay Simon dads
and powering their good characters I
like if that's your main green lantern
book that you're like that's the one
that's coming out early they're not
gonna have a Hal Jordan type Green
Lantern book till way later it's not
till I don't remember woods o July 27 so
its way further than everything else in
the DC a rebirth and that pisses me off
because Hal work Hal Jordans my guy like
I love Hal Jordan I read any Green
Lantern's got them in there we got to
wait that long toward come on Simon bad
power ring I'm okay with seeing them but
I'm not gonna pick up that title I'm
gonna wait for Hal Jordan but they got a
lot of restructuring retooling and it's
like I don't know how much of its gonna
be good you're getting these twice
monthlies that's a lot of money yeah and
you know i'm subscribed to a lot of DC
so it's like that's gonna cost a lot I
think that's a yeah you're dropping the
cover price down a buck but you're still
doubling in rehab yes yeah well and it's
just like for a lot of these I mean the
flash you know Green Lantern's that's
going to be twice shipping monthly green
arrow why are you doing green arrow
twice monthly I mean he's a good
character but I don't think he's that
big of a character to warn twice monthly
wonder woman's gonna be twice
monthly there's a lot of them they're
gonna be twice monthly and it's pretty
crazy and then they've got new titles
I've never heard of wacky race land
that's what it's called wacky race land
I have no idea um so super here girls oh
free comic book day so there's a lot
going on I'm not super like I'm not
super excited i'll have to see but you
know whatever see what happens whatever
you do not what is really nothing I
could do about it I love DC Comics I
like the tone of the comics a little bit
more than marvel I think generally
they're structured better Marvel with
like a lot of there like like universe
shattering things like what secret wars
there's a lot going on and it's not
always so cut and dry with like you know
the Spider Woman thing like oh this
business it's like you have to jump
around if that's one thing i like about
this series that was they kind of tell
you okay you've got eight and we'll
finish it out then which is kind of cool
but i think we'll see the aftermath in
all three of the titles of the spider
women he's like before all new all
different before all different like our
all-new whatever was Marvel now like I
was reading a Wolverine and x-men and
then one issue like Wolverines fine was
that the next issue he doesn't have his
healing powers and kid alphas dead I'm
like what yeah it happen to know a whole
other book that I wasn't subscribed to
but they didn't mention it right they
didn't even have a little tag no see
this book which DC will do that all the
time I have a little star like this
happened in this issue pick it up to
know what's going on they do this in the
Spider Woman series actually I do a
little like hey if you want to know who
she's talking about here go check out
just good ruined that's good because
they did not do that a lot of the books
i was reading and it's like I'm not
subscribed to a lot of these books
mm-hmm so I gotta go find this book and
figure out which one it is to just to
get caught up and it's like okay I got
one issue of like 17 of a random title
that I don't even read okay that's great
hmm you know so it's just I like DC a
little bit better really quickly quickly
you want to talk about the Batman Ninja
Turtles crossover okay this is an
awesome fun little crossover Batman geez
Ninja Turtles number five as of this
taping I was only number five out which
is an awesome awesome issue really sets
up the finale and number six combination
nice look at that and it is freaking
hysterical James tiny
fourth does it I think it's expertly
written I think it's captures everybody
Batman is captured properly is he's
written for Batman for Bentley an
eternal so Tyler knows what he's doing
Batman the turtles I think are captured
very well everybody's got their very
unique personality it's really conveyed
very well and it's funny it is so funny
Batman and Michelangelo together are
hysterical who would've ever thought it
and then race being a dick and being a
dick to Batman Batman's like committed I
don't do this I'm not just some he said
he's like oh just a billionaire getting
his kicks he's like he takes him to
crime alley and he shows him what
happened he tells him what happened to
his parents he's like that's why I'm
doing this and raced like ah damn dick
wrath wrath whatever I got a friend this
Raphael call him right yeah but um uh
yeah it's just it's a great little story
it's a little six-issue miniseries
eighth grade I want more I crossover
titles like idw DC if we could do more
of that like vertigo I mean I know it's
DC but still like if we do more that
that would be awesome like bring Lucifer
into the Batman or condo yeah but like
they've got i'm reading Lucifer from
vertigo and that's what awesome series
and like to see like Lucifer with
Constantine would be dope so like we I
want some crossovers I gotcha okay well
this was very important folks this past
or a week ago on May seventh was free
comic book day and we had our friend
Heather ruse go down to our friends at
graham cracker comics here in Wheaton
Illinois to check out what was going on
on free comic book day so we're gonna
cut away to a little piece be shot with
her so take it away
hey guys it's heather i'm here at the
graham cracker comics in wheaton because
it's free comic book day i am here with
Nick Nick hi um what comics did you pick
up today for a free comic quitting free
comic book day picked up the Civil War I
believe Civil War to serenity rom have
you seen Batman V Superman i did i did i
really love Batman have you seen the
doctor strange trailer did it look very
inception e i'm here with what's your
name Michael and Evan awesome okay what
comics are you planning on picking up
today for a free comic book day
whatever's new from valiant are you a
current subscriber I do get some marvel
titles favorite characters a lot of the
vertical line and again the Valiants
who's your favorite superhero even if
you had to pick one man after my own
heart i love batman 2 i'm here with
wilson wilson how long have has your
store been doing a free comic book day
it'll be 15 years what would you say is
one of the most popular comics people
have been picking up today on free comic
book day probably Civil War 2 because
the cap movie just came out there's an
awesome Bruce Lee one with about Bruce
Lee in modern day times I've been
pushing that really hard are you a team
cap or team iron man i hate captain
america so i'll go with iron man did you
see Batman V Superman I did that's
fantastic it's just awesome thanks very
much Wilson for chatting with us today
I'm sorry you had to go through this I'm
really sorry if you like toys check out
shocking out toy reviews as well
everyone should make sure they come down
to the wheaton graham cracker comics
free comic book day we got me poop dick
thanks Heather okay everybody so pick of
the week kind of self-explanatory take
your pick we also got some of the free
comic book day issues that Heather was
talking about we have civil war to a
little pre mood to that you got Suicide
Squad stuff we got capped America Steve
Rogers has a new shield pretty cool eh
looks awesome that's pretty cool we have
the tick as another tick I think you're
gonna make another movie or something
about think I heard something about that
recently yeah yup yup peter serafinowicz
a chick the only guy that could have
outdone it as that casting for me um the
hype is building I ought to mention this
earlier the DC superhero girls they're
super cute and they have all their
merchandise at target go buy it because
it's adorable they look like rat but
they're not friends no not at all best
we will fight know where i can fight
it's okay and serenity going strong
sorry Laura loves to maybe I and I'm
sure yeah like a dude who doesn't like
serenity and firefly oh you're bringing
up old wounds town I'm will never heal
yeah well it's pretty cool to have a
little hellboy comic in the back here to
aliens and aliens a lot a lot of cool
stuff enhance on the back there yeah
cool stuff so all of this is our picks
of the week so go ahead and check all
these books out I hope we did a good job
of explaining Marvel DC and a little bit
of idw and all this free comic book
stuff a guy going up so that's it for
this week next week we're going to be
talking about season one of dc's legends
of tomorrow a new show with a bunch of
characters from the flare overs so come
back the official name is phone call no
that's what they call it is floating
closet it's where all mean sounds weird
but that's what they call okay so we're
gonna be talking about the season want a
back show next week so poor where can we
find you on the social medias ah
facebook.com slash awesome Porter talk
about various chemical stuff movies
anything I really want that's not
related so never am yes indeed I in a
way where can we find you on space
online you know where to find me right
here right here Facebook Twitter right
here yeah you can check me out on my
myspace page my sangha sangha oh my god
i'll have a photograph don't
boy I all lead it by this time I'm
Twitter you could finally at awesome
underscore Walter I'm also have the
YouTube page a me and Porter both
comment a little bit i think i have
those too if you guys are nice we
comment on what you guys are saying if
you have some questions go ahead and ask
and we might answer them so and remember
keep commenting about what you want us
to see and give us a thumbs up if you
like this during an episode comment I'm
sorry don't like that's gonna have to
keep reviewing TV show them ugly yeah
share the video around should be right
now beep okay everybody so until next
week when we will be talking once again
about dc's legends of tomorrow for
everybody here I'm also been AZ and we
will see you on the next page